feels great it's I mean I feel like we
were so married before it's just like a
height rule sense of love I think Maksim
Chmerkovskiy and Peta Murgatroyd hit the
red carpet for the first time since
tying the knots et's sister show the
insider caught up with a newlyweds at
the 2017 industry Dance Awards on
Wednesday night they revealed the
highlight of their wedding day
I think there are a couple he sung for
me at the reception my special moment he
did so well I couldn't believe it I
thought somebody actually typed over his
voice like he wasn't actually singing
but he was singing and he taped
pre-recorded something he'd been there
two singing lessons for a week or
something
I carried the whole situation but I did
my best
the duo also gushed about sunshine today
like crawling all over me in bed and
just stood up and we're like little
things happen every day the funny thing
right now is he loves like fluffy and
beautiful textured like blankets it's
not really so he goes like this it's
just like and said this is about
returning to Dancing with the Stars for
season 25 we don't know yet still
kind of talking about that now I'm
trying to get out of the house to like
you know like separate from the baby for
a second but no we enjoying ourselves
right now we have a lot of projects
ahead and you know the most important
one is seven months and changed now so
we're kind of all about this kid and you
know we'll see what happens